hello and welcome football fans it is
Thursday night and welcome to mediocre
MetLife Stadium I and the incomparable
Adam Lefko and I am representing the
Eagles on Homer cast
I am a self-made man that is now a
champion and I'd like to introduce you
to my subpar co-host who got this job
because of his father hey Chris hey
Thank You loser Philadelphia announcer
who thinks a lot of himself but hey
let's not forget I wouldn't expect it
anything less from a group of fans that
throw batteries at Santa Claus and gosh
have a courtroom in the bottom of their
stadium would your gonna bag on our
Stadium okay Philadelphia doesn't mean
brotherly love in this telecast it
doesn't it's about law and order and I
think that Eli's play has been criminal
thus far I mean how can you defend a guy
whose pants constantly smell like poop
at the fear of a password - speaking of
poop don't your fans eat it once you
guys win once every 40 to 50 years great
organization speaking of eating it you
guys have been eating l60 in the last 20
times you've played the Eagles you lost
talking about the history books there
pal oh that's okay we don't really care
close the yearbook that's this year and
you got one more win than us and you're
the Super Bowl defending champions ha ha
ha that was an interesting laugh to do
touring a broadcast but I appreciate
your energy keys to the game what are
you doing for a Giants miracle wind
seeing as how all of the hope for this
season is long Wow we have exciting
offensive weapons and a future to look
forward to with Odell Beckham jr. and
say qualm Barkley that's what we're
looking forward to you guys right now
are just a disappointing underperforming
team that thinks Rocky's real than
Philadelphia sorry Philly it's a made-up
character rocky okay I think we can
agree on one thing though screw Dallas